thanks everyone so Steven recruited me
to share a session and I tried to chair
the first session but since he's seen
Tourette's talk a few times he predicted
that there might be like lots of lots of
questions and this would be like the
more difficult session to care so here I
am it's a very good introduction not not
at all controversial and I think Aaron
this will be the third time that Aaron
has seen this talking like the last
months I probably probably we've been
following each other across the country
okay so I I want to open up with a
summary and it is maybe they're a couple
controversial the points here so I want
to put them up front and please please
push back the first is it's kind of in
line with what we saw in the morning
sessions that I'm gonna beat up a little
bit on these group based notions of
fairness that are I would say somewhat
popular still and I'm gonna argue that
most of these mathematical measures of
fairness these group based mathematical
measures of fairness or poor proxies for
detecting discrimination I'll try to be
precise about what I mean by
discrimination and even worse attempts
to satisfy these formal notions of
fairness can lead to perverse decisions
perverse outcomes that many people would
call discriminatory and so not only can
you not measure the the discrimination
in many cases acting on these on these
measures can lead to discriminatory so
I'm gonna break this up into three parts
the first part just give you a little
bit of background on how big decision
making I think most of this will be
familiar to people that justice is and
I'll put everything in the context of
criminal justice using the the
ProPublica the standard ProPublica
example but to keep things concrete but
the arguments I'm going to be giving are
much more general okay so to make sure
we're all on the same page in this
pretrial setting what happens in the
u.s. is after you've been arrested
usually within 24 to 48 hours after
someone's been arrested a judge has to
make this high-stakes decision about
whether or not to detain you or release
you pending trial they're competing
interests here on the one hand they're
these social interests and even the
state's financial interest and that
detention is
pensa detention will well disconnect
people from their families often to lead
to loss of employment and on the flip
side there's a state's interest in
ensuring public safety and ensuring that
that people show up to trial when
they're asked to and so this is a hard
decision
it's consequential certainly and the way
that this is typically done still in the
u.s. is that judges user-experience they
use you know just knowledge of how
people might behave to make these
decisions and formally usually in pretty
quick like two-minute interviews and so
there's this movement to shift to an
algorithmic way of guiding these
decisions I'm making them exactly but
guiding the judicial decision by by risk
assessment and so there is a under there
both on the state side when someone is
detained there's a financial cost so
that's quite expensive that's one state
and also the employment yes yeah so it
is so it is just complex and really I
want to say they're these two I would
say in the extreme version of it they're
these two sides that that that one might
consider but in reality it's much more
intertwined but that's often how its
presented that the state might just say
let's have this kind of authoritarian
government if we only we don't want any
crime right now we're gonna lock
everybody up on the flipside if we
understand the cost of detention we
might release everybody and then there's
this interplay here so it's it's a
difficult balance to get okay so I'm
gonna make two key mathematical
assumptions for the rest of the
discussion and the first one
particularly is quite important so I
mean assume so these are risk
assessments and so how these risk
assessments work is you're trying to
predict something like they'll likely or
you trying to estimate the likelihood
that someone will commit a violent crime
if released something like that or the
likelihood that they won't show up to
court if released yeah and I'm gonna
assume so think of this as just like a
regression or something that's what's
actually using practice you have the
left-hand side and you have this label Y
and I'm gonna assume it's a true label
in two important senses so the first is
that it's there's no measurement error
so if I say that one might indicate that
you committed a violin
act in reality it's very hard to measure
that because if somebody committed an
act you don't you only know it through
proxy for example you know what if
they've been arrested or you know if
they've been convicted but usually it's
usually you don't know whether or not
they actually did it so I'm gonna assume
for now that we actually know that they
did I'm coming back to this at the end
but I also want a flag there's probably
one of the hardest things about fear
machine learning or whatever you want to
call this subfield is that we don't
actually have access to that that label
that we're trying to try to predict and
the second sense in which I mean this is
the true label is that it's a
counterfactual I want to know what would
have happened or what would happen in
the situation that I released them yeah
and you don't know that because you're
training on some data set some people
release some people or not so again it's
very difficult to estimate this thing so
it's true in the sense that it's both
the counterfactual and it's also
perfectly measured it's all of those are
put into this label so the very big
assumption and I'm gonna argue that even
under this assumption all sorts of crazy
things can happen and when you have
violations of this it's not that somehow
magically these these definitions that
people use fix everything and so I'm
just gonna put this out at the beginning
and I'll come back to it now the second
one is very much related to the the two
talks we saw this morning and that I'm
assuming we know the true risk and here
I'm gonna be very specific about what
the true risk is it means this
conditional probability so probability
that y equals one conditional on x
equals little X so this is a feature
vector and exhaustion ously we're given
this big X so this might be for example
your criminal history your age something
like this it's just like enumerates
various attributes about you and now
this is a particular instantiation of it
and if we have lots of data everything
is discrete this is just you could just
say this is the frequent you can
estimate this by a frequentist notion of
conditional probability in general
you're gonna have to do some smoothing
and this is where all these multicolored
bration notions come in so I'm gonna
sweep most of that under the rug and
again assume that we just have access to
this this true risk and notice there's
no like IDF P star here so we heard kind
of allusions to the kind of
philosophically difficult notion of
probability and here again if you think
about discrete lots of data in the
frequent in this frequentist world once
I give you the X then there's not a lot
of philosophical
goal issue there I'm not saying this is
somebody's inherent probability of
recidivism that's not a thing that I
think is personally well defined but I
can say conditional on these attributes
that's just a subgroup how many people
in that group are what proportion of
people in that group recidivate and
that's exactly the the meaning of this
thing so I'm trying to sidestep the
philosophical issues of p-star while
also being precise in then the choice of
accent matters as we'll see understand
we have this for all right so like I'm
just pushing on number two a little bit
because it seems as though if you want
it for all X in practice I would say so
it's not actually that bad in at least
in the criminal justice setting because
typically people are using something
like ten features and so they're so
you're right that in the extreme and so
this is where the generalization or is
coming from and this is it so so some
people just by statute whether or not
this is good or bad
we just don't release so if you've been
can if you're if you're an alleged
murderer typically you're not going to
be released and it might in fact be the
case that they actually have low
probability of failure to appear a
flight risk but we it's very hard to
estimate that and in part this is also
coming in on assumption one so again the
structure of this is not that I actually
believe these statements and I'm gonna
very much kind of beat up on this first
statement that I think this is a very
big assumption but the structure of the
argument give is even if we're in this
nice world all sorts of bad things can
happen okay so now what is the general
pipeline that we have features so think
of this as criminal history age etc we
make some prediction and then we're
gonna make some from this prediction
we're gonna make some decision so
like a probability then this is a binary
decision so detain yes or no and for
simplicity I'm I'm thinking everything's
binary yeah the way I drew this is
decision can depend both on the
prediction and also the features so in a
sense this is redundant I don't actually
need this formally but the reason I'm
putting this here is to highlight the
importance of the predicting prediction
aspect when coming to our ultimate
decision okay
so now let's just look at this first box
so here on the prediction given the
assumption the second assumption this is
just given to us once I tell you the
capital acts a set of features that I'm
considering this is just given to us we
have this by assumption okay and now
let's think about what the effect of the
feature set is on that in both of these
they have a human and machine aspect to
anything here you have to like you know
you have to decide on your feature set
even that's what's gonna be in the acts
here but once I set X this is just given
to us either we fit this model or we
just have some Oracle that's going to
tell us you know the decision again this
can be informed by statistics it can be
deformed informed by a model but you're
right that often this is the policy
aspect
okay so now what is what does this thing
look like what is this risk look like so
I can look it I can think about this so
if I fix my axe what is this what is
this object here it's a distribution of
risk across my population so in every
one in this room I can say you have a 5%
risk you have a 3% risk you have an 8%
risk you have a 2% risk that's a risk
it's deterministic I fit my model I it's
a deterministic risk for everybody in
the room and so where is a distribution
coming from this is a density where is
this coming from this is from the
distribution of my covariance in the
population so I might have a lot of
people that have a combination of
covariance that suggests that they're
low risk and then I might have a smaller
fraction of people that have a
combination of covariates that suggests
that they're higher okay so this is a
distribution of risk it's a
deterministic distribution of risk
across the population where the
distribution is coming from the fact
that we have a distribution of
covariance so that object clear it's so
now so this is really kind of the whole
point like once we understand this
object everything kind of falls out very
naturally so what are a couple
properties of this so the mean of this
depend no matter what my X is the mean
is going to be the same so the variance
the shape of this distribution can
change as a function of that X but the
mean is going to be fixed what does the
mean the mean is just the overall
recidivism in the population that's just
set right formally you can see this
because you're just taking you know the
double expectation if you want but it's
also I was saying intuitively clear and
what is a shape will look like well if I
don't have a very informative feature
set this is going to be tight low
variance around the mean if I have a
super informative feature set this is
going to be high variance and it's going
to be more or less bimodal around zero
in one so it's going to look like this
if I have a super informative feature
set and it's going to look like this if
I have a low variance not informative
features had tight around okay and so
the mean is fixed the variance the shape
of the distribution can change
as a function of X okay so now we
understand a little bit about where the
prediction is coming from and the
properties of the prediction and so how
do we make the decision there many ways
to make the decision and I would say one
in practice one common way is to
threshold the risk so you estimate
someone's risk of recidivism and now
you're gonna threshold it and say
everyone who is quote-unquote high risk
or above and you know of a certain a
certain point you might take one action
for example you might detain these
people you might release these people
yeah and where is this coming from
I'm either a couple of ways to kind of
justify this but you know one way to
think about it is that that there and at
first I wanna make clear this isn't the
universal this is common I've actually
never seen anything that like deviates
too much from this to practice but it's
not the only way that one could make
these types of decisions but I would say
it's a it's a reasonable way to start
making these types of decisions and it's
encoding the fact that out this
threshold let's say this threshold is a
50% what does that really mean that
means at the threshold I'm willing to
so at the threshold what does this mean
if the threshold is 50% it means that
I'm willing to release two people and
expect one crime that's what that
encodes and so if I'm really willing to
detain a lot of people I might set the
threshold way down here and say well I
really care about crime not detention
against this is immediate crime going to
this point in the short term and if I
really say no I think that unless
someone is super likely to go commit a
crime the cost of detention are so high
that I'm gonna put that threshold up
here so wherever I decide to put that
threshold that's a difficult policy
choice but it's encoding this fact that
that I have this this this sort of
trade-off between the tension and crime
and that where I said that threshold
depends on what that trade office I mean
you can so you can think of this in your
right in practice people often do both
in that I'm gonna have to combine these
things they put some weight according to
this and now I'm gonna like normalize
into units of crime for example I'll say
like 1010 missus of trial are the same
thing is one violent assault but then
I'll have to put it exactly so in New
York for example you can all use flight
risk so I'm being quite simple here to
gloss over the details yeah yeah and I
think there actually is this like sort
of moral argument for a wholly
considering flight risk over a crime
although in practice almost every
jurisdiction
language because twice you've talked
about individuals having risks rather
than what you expect when you release
two individuals with this rating yes but
you've told me that you really only care
about the second one that you're
assuming you don't have a notion so I so
I'm assumed so this is I would say using
kind of standard statistical terminology
this would be the an individual's risk
so if I fit a regression so if I fit a
regression with so you know a feature
vectors risk you don't know but I guess
some reason I'm pushing back on this is
that the notion of a true individual
risk is not well-defined and into
exactly and so I would say typically if
you were to like like for example we
talked about you know the probability of
an election outcome not the probability
of an election with a certain structural
feature and just a sort of standard
terminology in here I understand there's
like a little bit of slippage in that we
might really want to disentangle the
individual from the features that are
giving us that estimate but so when you
released those two people yes cuz you
took the threshold to be a half these
two people then you're assuming you're
predicting that one of them will but
you're not making any predictions in
individual one
I totally were not assuming any of that
I this is really what I'm really when I
say individual risk
I'm literally saying the thing that came
out of this it's like you fit your
regression and now you have a feature or
vector and now for every individual you
know really for every for every feature
vector but in practice even if we have I
mean the way that we we tend would go
from from for the way we typically make
predictions about individuals is we
assume some regularization and so you
Fisher logistic regression we're
assuming the world is smooth and so even
if we don't see anybody with the exact
same feature erector which is you know
true in general then we're still making
individual estimates of risk and so
what's going into that we're we're kind
of interpolating between the like
frequentist the world is divided into
all these people with with distinct kind
of probabilities that are easily
estimable and then some smoothness that
lets us interpolate in certain ways so
that's but all I'm really saying is this
thing I'm calling an individual
probability if you want to say if every
times the individual probability you
want to convert this to probability of
an individual with that feature vector
that's totally fine that doesn't change
the discussions over a randomly selected
person that's why it depends that's why
it matters a lot with this big X's right
so big X's so when you see that it's
reasonable when you have lots of data
use
you find this just given the features
are using the reason able to assume that
individual who has this feature has the
first so the second is much harder the
first is saying that if I give you the
little AK so if I give you the big ax if
I have a lot of data you imagine this
isn't quite right but I can imagine the
world is into these discrete buckets and
so now I can just estimate pretty
accurately what's happening in each of
these discrete buckets the second is a
much stronger statement and actually do
believe it in some cases like in
baseball we have kind of reason to
believe that there's not some like
secret feature that's missing that's
really gonna let us you know
dramatically estimate outcomes much
better than we have so informally you
try what how do you get these things you
just like try a bunch of stuff and maybe
you see some diminishing returns
information and you feel like okay well
I haven't come across that secret sauce
yet so maybe I'm converging to some true
probability although again referencing
this the first out of dog this morning
it's very difficult to know what that
means the true probability okay so we've
kind of in contrast to the the single
threshold we have this double threshold
weight that we can think about things
you say might be if we have two groups
any two groups will have two different
risk distributions
that's not something inherent about the
group it's just saying the covariate
distribution is different in different
groups and so we'd expect different
distributions at risk and we might have
different thresholds for different
groups now a lot of people would think
that this is not fair
and I kind of hate using that word but
I'm going to use it here and where is
that intuition coming from well there
are couple ways at first it's like
there's this like badge inferiority that
might be saying well why am i subjecting
different groups to different standards
another kind of a Cana metric way of
thinking about this is there's a loss of
efficiency in that I'm detaining these
relatively low risk members of the blue
group and I could if I switch to a
single threshold then I wouldn't have
that issue and I could detain
fewer people for the same amount of
crime prevented an expectation so that's
one econometrics a of thinking about why
there's some value to having a single
threshold and this is also goes under
the name of so it's efficient in this
very particular sense if I care about
immediate attention and immediate crime
that I'm so again I don't want to
suggest this is the only thing that one
can do but I do want to point out that
this is a pretty reasonable thing that
first of all that is done in practice
and I would say is something that's kind
of has these like legal and ethical ways
of thinking about it that but also I
would say feels reasonable and well
we're the rest of the talk is gonna be
is is looking at how different
definitions treat this example and so
we're gonna think of this as a litmus
test of sorts where when different
definitions fail to capture this thing
or automatically would say this is an
unfair situation then that that is
something that I view is problematic
right presumably our selection of X
directly affects how differently the
single I'll talk about that so stuff
these three kind of ways of thinking
about there's a large class of thinking
about fairness it cannot not a complete
taxonomy but I think these are common
ways of thinking about it calibration
here I don't mean multi calibration I
just mean ordinary calibration so I'll
get back to this in a minute
classification parity this is things
like false positive rate and an anti
classification they're not using
protected group characteristics like so
I'll go through each of these slowly and
so now kind of highlighted results
calibration typically does not preclude
taste face discrimination classification
parity almost always leads to taste
based discrimination and ante
classification can be to walk through to
these so first what does calibration
mean calibration since a real data this
is from the ProPublica about our County
data this is this is our analysis but
they show something similar here's a
risk score so one to ten is scaled here
in in deciles of risk nationally but you
can this maps to probabilities and now I
can say for any kind of risk score what
is the empirical probability of
reoffending for different groups and
what we see here is that that's it's
it's similar and what I'm kind of
slipping under the rug here is we never
actually know the empirical probability
because we don't have that true label
why but we have a proxy for it and so
that's what's being plotted here but it
seems that if I tell you that someone is
have a score of seven then their actual
recidivism rate is comparable across
across different groups of defendants
here
so that's what calibrations so now how
do I have a calibrated score and still
discriminate so this is very much in
line with these examples that that we
saw this morning
I just want to play this out in this
case it's a slightly different example
let's say that this is my rule I have
these are the true probabilities I'm
just gonna say that I have a look like a
rich set of X's and so I'm gonna
estimate these things this is what I
believe that someone's probabilities
conditional on this rich set of X's are
and I know that you are gonna make some
decision and detain everyone above
greater equal to 0.5 okay now I got him
the albedo designer I want to
discriminate or I want I want to cause
you to make different decisions what am
I gonna do and I really like this blue
group and I want to make sure that no
one in this blue group is detained so
what am I gonna do I mean something very
simple I'm just gonna take these people
these hide these people that I believe
are high-risk and there's people that I
believe are low risk I'm gonna average
them together and I'm gonna say they're
all medium risk this is very much in
line with the example that Michael gave
earlier of taking this like 50 percent
group and then splitting it up into the
zero percent and the one percent cream
but here I'm just doing it reverse I'm
taking the people that I think are high
risk people I think are low risk and
then making them all look medium risk
and the point is that all of them are
now to the left of this threshold so
nobody is ticked and the stores are so
calibrated in so conditional on risk
score the actual empirical probability
of recidivating is the exact is is what
you would expect and so you can't tell
from the outside that something funny
has gone on unless you have access to
more information unless you actually can
discriminate or distinguish between
these these medium risk people over here
and these medium risk people over here
if you know that somehow they were they
they look different and so you have to
have access to some side information to
do that so in print so this is like not
really gonna happen in practice this
type of strategic manipulation but I
think it could happen I mean this is
like a particularly crude way of doing
it but I do think they're versions of
this that can and have had have happened
in practice so you can think of this as
a version of redlining and so what was
happening in red line
is that Bank do not want to land extent
credit to certain individuals so how
could black invidual Zin particular so
how do they do this they said well we're
the only feature we're gonna consider or
one of the main features we're gonna
consider is where you live
so that's predictive of risk so it's not
like a crazy thing to consider where you
live but but the problem is that there
are a lot of other features that they
could have used it could have used
individual credit histories and said
that even if you live in a high-risk
neighborhood a high credit rich
neighborhood which in reality is where a
lot of black applicants were living then
you're gonna be denied credit even if
you are relatively credit worthy and so
this is a version of exactly that I'm
gonna go to my my high-risk neighborhood
even though I can separate that
high-risk neighborhood into people who
are low risk and high risk I'm not gonna
do that extra step and I'm gonna say
everyone there is relatively high risk
and now I have a reason based on
calibrated scores to deny credit to
those and so this is one argument for
using all of the information that you
have available when estimating these
these resources Jamie's comment the risk
that acts as you use matter and if you
don't use all the available information
then that can lead to these these types
of problems but it's actually it's still
trickier because the information that's
available is not just like well defined
thing there is costs typically to
getting information and so you have to
make this trade-off at some point of
saying do I want to spend the money to
get better information or not and Dokken
obviously have pretty pretty serious
consequences for your risks estimates
but I at least want to put that out
there and so at least if you have
information available to you that's like
zero cost is sitting in your database
and you don't use it that seems
problematic
just in practice calibration is what
like the criminal risk score people like
care most about like sort of like the
classical people design I don't think
it's I think that's what they say and
only that's actually what they care
about fundamentally because what they're
doing is they're fitting logistic
regression and they're using all the
data and that's a much stronger thing
than calibration that's really getting
very close to the solution of multi
calibration we don't use that
terminology and it's really getting
close to our intuitive notion of what it
means to say someone's like true
probability at risk even though that's
not fully defined so it's a much
stronger thing that they that they care
about even though they don't use those
words so typically they'll show
something like this but the point is
just looking at something like this
doesn't tell you very much knowing the
process by which the scores were
generated tells you a lot more
okay so now I want to switch to that was
kind of the brief overview of
calibration so now I want to switch to
cause classification parity and here
there this is anything that can be
computed computed from a confusion
matrix roughly something about false
positive rates false negative rates
precision we call all of these these
types of things and I'm gonna talk about
false positive rates but the argument
extends to just refresh your memories
what is false positive rate in this
particular context this means among
people who would not have reoffended
what proportion were deemed high risk
and here it's just you know you said
spider classification so among people
who inada reoffended what proportion are
deemed high risk and you can compute
this across the different groups of
subgroups of the population for example
ProPublica did this for block defendants
and white defendants and determined that
the false positive rate for block
pendants was about twice as high and
quite kill quite big 30 percent versus
50 15 percent or for white pants so
quite large gap in false positive rates
across groups
now I'm gonna argued out that this
doesn't mean exactly what what it's
commonly interpreted as meaning so you
look at these members and about this
feels like really yeah like something is
has gone wrong the algorithm itself I'm
saying some more more nuanced argument
here about what's what's going on but
I'll try to work here and the issue is
at a very high level what is the issue
the issue is that we typically think of
error metrics as comparing different
models on the same data set and here
what's happening is something different
we're looking at the same model on
different data sets different subgroups
of that original data set so effectively
different data sets and we take this
when you take an error metric we compare
the same model across the different data
sets
that's an apples to oranges comparison
that is not at all the same as the
typical apples to apples comparison of
different models on the same data set so
it's a very kind of subtle difference
but that difference has enormous impact
on the interpretation of these numbers
okay so let's just again mechanically
see how these things are calculated we
have our two groups remember any two
groups will likely have different
distributions of risk that's not a
statement about kind of like like some
sort of moral statement about whether
one group is riskier than another just
saying that the core vary distribution
is different across groups and so we
have different estimates of risk of
cross these two groups and here we're
gonna take this kind of simple threshold
intended in released you know now let's
just compute false positive rates for
for the blue group how does this work
again it's among people who do not
reoffending redeemed high-risk these are
the probabilities that they reoffended
sis add them up that's not quite right
but some approximation of that will give
us the denominator and the numerator is
among those people how many are to the
right of this line so we do this and we
get 2 over 8 so we get 25% false
positive rate would be the exact same
thing for the red group so now they're
this is a higher risk group on average
higher recidivism rate so the proportion
that do not reoffending to be smaller
and in this particular example more of
these people who do not reoffended right
of the line
so again just mechanically we have a
higher false positive rate about 40%
false positive rate in this example
recapping we have very big differences
in false positive rate where's it coming
from from this very simple reason that
the distribution of risk is different
across these two groups so even if we
apply the same threshold we will just
get different false positive rates ok so
again it's not because there was a
different standard being applied to
different groups it's because different
groups have different distributions of
risk so applying the exact same standard
leads to different false positive rates
so now so this is what's happening so
this is just kind of a stylized example
but it's pretty close to what's what we
think is happening in the real data so
here our estimates of recidivism for for
individuals in the Popol Vuh data and we
can see this heavier tail for black
defendants and again we don't know
exactly what the like so if true risk is
for individuals but these are
estimates of that and we see that that
the tail is happier for black defendants
then white defendants into that's in
line with where these higher false
positive rates are coming from so now
kind of relating this to classical econ
this is what's called infer marginal
statistic false positive rates are infer
marginal in that the average over the
entire distribution so to compute false
positive rates I have to know something
about the entire distribution but ideas
of discrimination particularly taste
based discrimination or ideas about
what's happening at the margin so this
idea that you apply a single standard to
all individuals in the population that's
a margin that's like talking about
what's going on at the margin but the
summary statistics things that you can
typically compute from a confusion
matrix are integrating over the entire
distribution it's about for this
mismatch is coming from so this is like
an idea this is one of the reasons why
it's so difficult to estimate
discrimination in human decisions
because we don't usually have the entire
distribution of risk and so it's hard to
know if people are applying the same
standard that's where a lot of our work
is actually he's pushing on is
understand discriminatory okay so now
I'm going to kind of go back to this
example and and say why this is even
weirder so you might say okay well false
parts anything mechanically came from
this this difference in distributions of
a risk but there still might be
something in there like the group itself
might be by experiencing harm when
you're when your threshold and using a
single threshold to make these types of
decisions and I would say yes that's
possible like that's it's not to say
that single threshold is the only thing
that one might want to do you might want
to have two concessions for different
groups do you think the equilibrium
properties of that type of decision rule
are good and some in some sense but I'm
also going to push back a little bit and
say that it's not a priori obvious that
just because false positive rates are
different than the group with the higher
false positive rate is being harmed so
why is it's a very simple example so
let's look at this this red group the
red group is the one with the higher
false positive rate to 40% well close to
rate now what am I gonna do
I'm just going to go out and arrest a
bunch of college protesters there's a
bunch of low-risk people on the anti
population and I in that what's gonna
happen when I do this well all these
people were identified as low-risk by
the algorithm correctly no one's
decision is going to change except for
these people are gonna be released or
they gonna be immediately arrested and
then released and so what's gonna happen
these folks are mostly gonna end up in
the denominator over here
no one's gonna end up in the numerator
and none of them are to the right of
that line and so my false positive rate
just mechanically Falls okay so I've
gone from this situation where one might
say well false positive rates are high
for this group so this group is
experiencing real harms to this we're
all of a sudden the false positive rates
equal but the groups are not the group
arguably is worse off in this in this in
the interest of time I'll I'll postpone
this to the end and so again this isn't
to say that this is that the only thing
to do is to draw a threshold and maybe
something funny is happening but without
any extra information you don't know if
this is a good situation or a bad
situation because I can easily flip what
you might naively say just by changing
this distribution of risk so now knowing
something more about what this
population is it's very hard to
interpret things like call sponsors
okay so again all of these definitions
that that that precision recall
false-positive all migrated they all are
infirm are gional they all have exactly
the same statistical property of
requiring the full distribution of risk
to compute even though at least some
common notions of equity depend on
what's going on only at the margin and
that's where this this mismatch is
coming so now let me just in the
interest time let me skip to the to the
I know I'm going to not talk about the
ante classification but these I'll show
the reference to a paper at the end and
let me just talk a little bit about by
some video but it's important so I can
buy some did that sound like a totally
well-defined
idea of what this means so I'm gonna I'm
gonna give two interpretations of what
bias in the data might mean and then
play out how what the what the
consequences of these things are so the
first is biased labels this is what I
alluded to at the beginning that why it
doesn't perfectly measure what we care
about in a second is bias predictors in
that the features are differentially
predictive so this is a huge problem and
this is not as big a problem when you
don't have biased labels okay so that's
what I'll that's well right okay so let
me give you an example I think this is
probably example that than many people
know st. George's Hospital in the UK to
help this algorithm to sort medical
school applicants train the label here
was passed emissions decisions that's
not a crazy label I would say in this in
the setting the problem is that path
decisions were biased against women and
so the algorithm just codified this this
discrimination and the issue again is
wanted mismatch that the that the label
the true label is something like how
successful this person be if they're
admitted into the program that's very
hard and so the proxy label is what did
somebody decide in the past now to the
extent that the proxy label is not well
aligned with the true label you have
this codifying of discrimination
so there's something we always have to
contend with in in the in the criminal
justice setting what does this mean this
is something like the the difference
between whether or not someone committed
a crime committed an assault and whether
or not they were arrested or convicted
for that assault and even conviction is
not clearly not not the appropriate
process or not closed proxy to what is
happening in reality and so if you think
of something like drug arrests this is
super problematic and so we know from
survey data we have strong reason to
believe that drug use is similar across
groups but because of heavier policing
in high crime high minority
neighborhoods we will arrest somebody
and ultimately convict them for using
drugs more like more often if there are
a minority in it there other crimes like
violent crime it seems less prone to
this but we don't really know and this
is part of the difficulty here is we
don't know what we don't know and so we
don't actually have those true labels of
the other day and so we're always making
something in France but the whole police
is if it's not street crime it's less
sort of less acceptable to this
observation bias so it's very difficult
so now so that's a clear problem on the
biased label side on the Weisse
predictor side what does this mean so I
think one intuitive sense in which we
might have biased predictors is that the
same usually this marijuana arrests
example again is that is that minority
users are more likely to be arrested
than why users we have that fact and so
therefore if I'm trying to make some
prediction of let's say like violent
crime based on the number of times
you've been arrested actually means less
if you are if you're a minority than if
you're white so if I know that that that
I'm try to predict the violent crime so
there's no bias let's let's just assume
that there's no biased label problem
here but still let's say every time you
were arrested for marijuana every time
you have a marijuana arrest that might
increase my estimation of you by like 1%
on average that you will commit this
violent crime if released but the
problem is that number doesn't really
mean the same thing across different
groups because your
likely to be arrested if you're black
then if you're like hey so statistically
that's a very simple thing to fix if you
believe the labels are unbiased you just
fit two different models and you say
okay well maybe every marijuana arrest
will add half a percentage point if you
are black you know had two percentage
points or one percentage point one-half
percent points if you're white something
like this okay so this is statistically
very kind of easy thing to do it's
contrary to this idea of anti
classification education I didn't really
go over it but it just means this idea
that you don't use protected
characteristics explicitly and here we
are using those protected
characteristics explicitly to correct
for the fact that there's different
amounts of information in the labels of
stuff in the in the features themselves
so this is I think a nice kind of
description of this by sandy Mason and
her bison by side paper in New Orleans
when I worked there as a public defender
the significance of a rest vary by race
if a black man had three arrests in his
past it suggested only that he had been
living in New Orleans black men arrested
all the time for trivial things if a
white man had three arrests to past
arrests on the other hand two suggested
I was really bad news so exactly the
same thing that we have different
information and you're the same
predictor might need different things in
different groups we actually haven't
found empirical evidence for this
although we're not okay in New Orleans
but conditional on all the other
features we don't see differential
predictive power in race although we see
huge differences for gender so it's just
like sort of interesting empirical
observation that that once you condition
all lots of stuff the impact of race
seems to be small in the example that
we're looking at although I do suspect
there are examples where that's not
gender it's it's quite oh okay so now
I'm just wrapping up the last minutes I
think there's all these formal
mathematical definitions of fairness but
kind of the main thesis of this talk is
that many just these definitions cannot
accommodate common understandings I'll
be quality particularly something like a
single threshold rule apply to our best
estimates risk and that's not to say
that this is the only way to think about
equality I don't think that is the only
way to think about equality but again I
do think of this as a litmus test and if
these these notions like false positive
rates are really being used widely and
failed to capture what practitioners are
doing and also where
our legal system I would say as has his
that is okay we should least think about
what the implications of those are those
formal definitions are in the last point
is that algorithms are not pulse and so
algorithms I just wrap this up and then
I'll oh this is the last slide so the
these statistical algorithms what is the
roll them they're good at synthesizing
information and so the algorithms might
say we'll give me a bunch of features
I'm gonna give some estimate of some
outcome happening they don't tell us
what to do and so in the pre trial
setting you know one thing that many are
advocating for including myself is to
limit limit money bail entirely this is
where California is heading and we might
say or go to these non-custodial
interventions and so even if someone is
high risk or high flight risk we know
statistically if there are better high
risk of flight we might not just detain
them we might say well let's get you
child care let's get you transportation
and let's deal with that underlying
issue of lowering someone's risk and so
the algorithm can correctly tell us that
someone is high risk of some certain
adverse impact it's not telling us what
to do and I think a lot of the issues
that people have with equity in the
criminal justice system is not the
actual estimation of risk itself but
what we're doing with that thing at the
end and so saying that because I've
estimated you to be high risk I'm going
to impose all these and harsh conditions
on you in many cases I would say it's
not it's not appropriate and so we can
but it is accurately telling us ways
that we can intervene for example in
rolling so that's actually one of the
directions that we're moving in now is
is developing interventions to lower
someone's risk if you're interested in
more of this check out our papers this
pretty much is the the paper version of
the talk and this other paper came a
little bit earlier and it's it's going
into more technical details this and if
you're interested in learning more about
the interventions that that we're
starting to roll out please check out
our
your questions well Charlie sets up a
comment to go back at that slide in the
title of this life to go back to it and
says math does not equal equity I know
that's not consistent with the content
of your talk we're saying there are
particular notions mathematically in
fairness which do not think math is very
helpful for reasoning so you're actually
showing why this particular notion it
doesn't imply serious I agree I did that
so the catalyst I was Massa not equal to
equity not that it's not sort of
something that's that's useful so I do
think it's useful but I what I see and
this is maybe this is a controversial
statement but I do think it's it's true
that a lot of papers will simply posit a
mathematical definition and equate it
with justice or fairness and this maybe
is just like loose language but I think
it's important that whenever we write
down any formalization of an idea that
we understand this is a particular
formalization that it's not the kind of
broader sense in which we care about
these issues so that's that's where I'm
coming from
so I do certainly think I mean of course
I'm trained as a mathematician I like I
kind of been professionally required to
believe that the stuff is useful in a
sense but I also think it's important to
not kind of time we can take the
remaining questions over lunch
the